ciao ragazzi ben tornata nella puntata
di cucina buttata noi solitamente
ringraziamo sempre che ci suggerisce i
piatti che andremo a fare no questa
volta è impossibile perchè perchè su
instagram da quando gigi ed ha fatto la
sua pasta alla vodka io non so quanti
messaggi sono arrivati follia pura
qualora lo sapeste gige di da condiviso
un po come elisabetta canalis
il suo pollo alla piastra sua ricetta
per fare questo piatto di pasta alla
volt campora non è la cosa più
innovativa del mondo fa un po anni 90
2000 ma un sacco di persone ci hanno
chiesto di farla e quindi credo che se
arrivato il momento di provarla
gli ingredienti per fare la pasta alla
bocca dei gigli ed il avremo bisogno dei
misurini per misurare e cose americane
olio cipollotti concentrato di pomodoro
panna da cucina peperoncino mag e burro
parmigiano basilisco sale e pepe e
quando si parla di ricette americane
questi sono fondamentali per gigi
dividono meravigliano poi a che chiamano
ne so gente che abita lì misura con
questi noi lasciamo un link per
acquistare questi qua che secondo me
sono perfetti qua sotto
altrimenti non lo sono andati a mani e
come le pare avvio l'acqua della pasta
che se non ci mettiamo troppo tempo le
mie birkenstock se volete adesso deve
smettere seguirmi
e intanto faccio partire qui prendiamo
un quarto di taza pino riempiamo d'olio
ora questa è una cosa un po da sfigati
perché l'olio non si misura si getta per
questo che proprio buono toscano quindi
o rosico per usarlo per le ricette che
magari sono prendiamo lo spicchio
d'aglio debutteranno le mani di aglio
perché te ne dico per operare e ricoh io
ti ci faccio il bidet con quest'anno
anzi di situazione supposta non lo trovi
più tagliamo di quanti versiamo dentro
cipollotto togliamo la testina c
prodotto seguono una delle cose più
buone che esistano già tanto scusami è
caduta la cipolla è un uomo una donna
chi agisce hadid e ti pone delle più
grandi modelle al momento che cacchio
vero è un golfista nonché lo sportivo
più pagato lo scorso anno ha detto noi
dediche gianardi il numero già sentito
vago arrivino a rimini a rimini nel
frattempo prendiamo un quarto di tazza e
la riempiamo di concentrato di pomodoro
quasi brucia tutto questo punto noi
aggiungiamo il concentrato di pomodoro
perché quando fa il compleanno tu sì lo
sapevo
però adesso bisogna farla andare un
pochino così la panna da cucina a questo
punto questa è proprio americanata un
cucchiaio solo di vodka pensa molto di
più dai viola
giriamo e facciamo evaporare tutto
quanto in modo a lasciare solamente il
sapore via delle cugine libiche che
c'entro io con le persone che ci hanno
detto di farla io allora ragazzi intanto
che questo qui va aprendo un peperoncino
e lo taglio è scritto che ficca
all'interno di posso garantire è una
piccante per niente lo scherzo di
mangiare dolci all'intero mangia
peperoncino intervallo no ragazzi
no no ma io muoio
[Risate]
scusami dedicate no guarda io sono tre
ma di un intero un pezzettino picchia
allora nella busta c'è scritto super
piccante ecco il braccino supergigante
intanto prendo un cucchiaio da terre di
peperoncino che glielo vado a buttare
dentro pepe sale giriamo al timer
partito 225 grammi di spaghetti lei usa
delle specie di orecchiette raga non
maso sentire da non ci ha fregato
spaghetti alla chitarra che cosa si è
mangiato da terra questa mista mangiare
la pasta cruda che è meglio secondo me
comunque salone della pasta e gigi ed un
quarto di partigiano e ci buttiamo qua
dentro
ma nella vodka che fine ha fatto
esattamente in tutto questo c'è tutto
tranne bocca io aggiungo l'acqua di
cottura intanto ragazzi
un cucchiaio di burro a te pare mica
calco se magna nuovo la gracco ogni
giorno oddio piena regola soggeti col
crac
prendiamo un bel piatto ragazzi mi
raccomando se lo fate a casa questo
piatto tagga temi su instagram perché lo
voglio vedere ciò che fate sentire tipo
pazzesca questa pasta meravigliosa culto
dio se non fosse che il canto della
terra stasera to cane fedele che vuole
solo non avrebbe neanche se non fosse
piccante io credo che lui vorrebbe
solamente si è cosparsa sui gattini che
stanno nell'altra stanza ho una
curiosità l'odore non è male su questo
canale credo di aver fatto decisamente
di peggio ok raga poi in piatto che
altro serve un palato raffinato
oddio oddio oddio che ci siamo la
trasportiamo da questo no è che cala ma
via da quello al fornello da questo a
questo ma non salta mai incontrato manco
morto
ragazzi ma pazzo né allora occhi su di
me prendiamo la pasta e iniziamo a
girarla adagiamo qui questo è solo il
primo step per cuore ne faccio una più
piccola prendendo una forchetta prendo
una forchettata di pasta che in questo
momento è la cosa più alla pata del
mondo giro creando la stessa cosa ma e
dimensione più piccola adagio nel
cerchio di prima vola prendo una piccola
forchettina più che io con le mani sopra
e non so perché basilico spezzato sopra
che tutto fa tranne sopra quindi uno
sembra quasi bella raga pronti per
l'assaggio
sarebbe l'aspetto di una pasta da sei e
mezzo ma con la mia presentazione
secondo me arriviamo al 7 più umile devo
dire che l'impianto è molto molto bello
come il piazzamento io do 8 e che meno
perché è lui hanno fatto la rosa di
guglielmo e carina graziosa ma voi state
imbriaghi davvero gli do un 7 7 meno
bene io arrivo tanto il ritardo sugli
appalti erano pacchetto alla alla vodka
della mia amica nonché collega gigi
hadid ma bellissimo un po scarno se devo
essere sincera lo chef stato un po
tirchio come 7 cioè un bel piatto ma non
è che mi avete fatto chi fa che cosa e
colore allora devo dire che lui è
gradevolissimo si sente punto la bocca
inesistente l'autore no ma tu lo sai
riconoscere dissapore perché a me piace
molto il le do un 7 meno l'odore mi
arriva fino a qua viene svampa che sta
prendendo a cazzotti e piacevole pure
commodore e cioè questo concentrato di
pomodoro e basilico risultano fuori cioè
un odore e un po particolare non
prettamente italiano gli do un 7
quell'aroma quell'odore alternativo che
non mi aspettavo ma che comunque non mi
dispiace è buonissimo è super intenso
all'odore darei un otto armatore però
che non riesco ad identificare
stranamente però io sono qui gen
forse anche per questo che non riesco
bene ad identificarla sapore ho una
curiosità
sette sono le è buonissima mi piace non
sa di coca secondo me è buonissima fatta
dal sottoscritto
bisogna andare bene non è male ma io
sento qualcosa di diverso rispetto agli
ingredienti che abbiamo messo e non
vorrei che sia la roma alla roma della
bocca anzi fossi stato in guglielmo io
aveva alzato un pò più il gomito con la
dose della bocca 8 meno la cosa che mi
incuriosisce di più
la ricetta di cc hadid vodka inesistente
devo fare forse un'ora di meditazione
per sentire la volta buona
cioè buon piatto semplice anzi lo
definirei cento il peperoncino basili
cioè fresca non è un brava cgil brava un
sette e mezzo non glielo leva nessuno un
applauso per gigi vediamo se la mia
collega merita tale appellativo bona fa
piccante permesso pomodoro che c'era
tipo il concentrato ecco fregoni farei
un piatto si premono immagine un pochino
mandava di modo in passato di trovarlo
nel menu tipo di un pub o comunque di un
posto dove non paghi troppo quindi per
una piatta forse la lotta non si sente
ma si sente in altri modi
io pagherei 12 euro e forse fare le
pennette majid poco italiana con questa
palla
se leggessi in un ristorante e passa
alla bocca a me queste cose intrigano
quelli co bravo probabilmente anche se
mi tufferebbero sarei disposto a darmi
[Risate]
sbaglio senso aprire da restivo un 15 16
euro
non sono d'accordo con voi per quanto
riguarda il prezzo io questa la pagherei
78 che se comunque della mangi un pezzo
di peperoncino 78 euro 10 se proprio
devo mi devo dissanguare quanto pagherei
per questo piatto fatto dalle dolci
manine this is he ha un valore è però il
giusto è un piatto da 78 euro se lo chef
se decide detto è un po meno tirchi o
con le porzioni perché qua non è che
stiamo fa la nouvelle chiusi non lo do
uno arriva le quattro sperando di
pranzare invece è comunque ragazzi siamo
arrivati al fine di questo video
ricordatevi se fare di questo piatto vi
prego academy su instagram fatemi sapere
sempre piaciuto no metteteci un pollice
in su per il quale fosse preceduto
proprio questo video in generale
iscrivetevi al canale attirate da
campana le notifiche e fateci sapere
sempre qua sotto e solista per anche
cosa mi piacerebbe vedere nei prossimi
episodi ci vediamo giovedì con un nuovo
video alle 12
ciao
aspetto non c'è un cane che sta dormendo
sotto questo tavolo del progetto beh in
impiatta mento fa tanto devo esser
sincero sarebbe aspetto di una pasta da
quando parlo io fa questa cosa